es un encuentro de emergencia para
manifestar
y nuestra preocupación por el exterminio
a que estamos siendo sometidos son 283
asesinatos que se mantienen en la
impunidad no hay ninguna acción efectiva
de parte del gobierno en representación
del estado se desfinanció el presupuesto
para la paz estamos planteando que aquí
hay que montar un piloto por la vida un
piloto por la vida implica de que llegue
el estado de manera institucional a uno
de los municipios más golpeados acá en
el departamento que es el municipio de
argelia necesitamos que el estado llegue
al territorio pero no con el uniforme
sino de manera interinstitucional